today we're joined with the honorable
bill blair president of the queen's
privy council for canada and minister
for emergency preparedness the honorable
dominique leblanc minister of
intergovernmental affairs infrastructure
and communities the honorable mona forte
president of the treasury board the
honorable marco mendicino minister of
public safety
the honorable
omar olgabra minister of transport as
well as yazir naqvi the member of
parliament for ottawa center they will
be providing an update regarding the
situation in ottawa right now
just a reminder for questions
please raise your hand we will start
with
please raise your hand on zoom rather
i'm told we have 20 minutes of questions
after the remarks so i'll hand over the
floor to the ministers and then we'll
proceed to questions
well thank you very much for the kind
introduction
good afternoon everyone and and thank
you for joining us here today
before we begin i would like to take the
opportunity to acknowledge that i am
speaking to you today from the
traditional territory of the mississauga
of the credit
the events that have taken place in
ottawa over the past 10 days have had a
significant and frankly unacceptable
impact on the lives and the freedom of
people who live here who conduct
business here and among all canadians
coming to do business in their nation's
capital and since the outset we have
encouraged those who are engaged in this
process to obey the law and to respect
the rights of their fellow citizens
to the people of ottawa and on behalf of
our government let me first say that we
share in your frustration and deeply
regret that the actions of these
protesters continue to inflict such
disruption in your neighborhoods
the rcmp the parliamentary protective
services and other federal partners have
remained in close contact with the
ottawa police service and we continue to
play a significant coordination role
between these agencies but let me be
clear
it is not the role of any government to
direct law enforcement operations it is
the responsibility of the police of
jurisdiction and in this case the ottawa
police service to maintain public order
and to uphold the rule of law they must
have the appropriate resources and they
do have the appropriate tools and
authorities that they require to keep
their communities safe
and in circumstances where
the events exceed the capacity of the
police service to respond as they are
required to do
there are well-established authorities
for the police to seek assistance and as
the federal government we are here to
provide support to local police and we
have responded affirmatively to every
request for assistance that we have
received to help strengthen the ottawa
police services ability to protect the
people of ottawa
there have been also ongoing work among
all of our our federal departments to
ensure that we are mobilizing all of the
resources that are required and and
requested by the province of ontario and
the city of ottawa to provide every
support that is required
yesterday as many of you are aware the
city of ottawa declared a state of
emergency
and in response to this the federal
government is proposing to convene a
trilateral table with municipal and
provincial partners i've reached out
today to to the the solicitor general
for the province of ontario and to the
mayor of ottawa to to convene a table
that will allow us to keep lines of
communication open during what is a
fluid and dynamic situation and to
respond with speed and efficiency to
meet the city's needs
let me be very clear however that this
is simply building upon the active and
ongoing conversation collaboration and
coordination that has taken place on
every political level between our
respective officials and will allow us
to keep these lines of communication
open there has been open and active
engagement for from our senior public
officials the provincial senior public
officials and the city of ottawa to
provide support we also know that there
is close communication and collaboration
between the municipal police services
provincial police services and the rcmp
i would now like to take the opportunity
to address those individuals who are
still participating in this event
many of the actions that have taken
place over the course of this
demonstration have been unlawful and
frankly disrespectful to the rights and
and freedoms of all canadians it is well
past the time to bring this protest to
an end
canada is a peaceful nation and we are
often served as an example of hope to
countries around the world and we look
after our neighbors and we treat each
other with respect in this country
we do not threaten or intimidate our
fellow citizens we do not desecrate the
national war memorial we don't dishonor
statues dedicated to national heroes
and we do not tolerate individuals who
wave flags riddled with symbols of hate
and discrimination
the freedom to engage in lawful peaceful
assembly and process is is a fundamental
charter right however when an event is
no longer peaceful when the event is
disrupting the lives and jeopardizing
the livelihoods of fellow canadians
local residents have been harassed
harassed for wearing mass business
owners have been forced to close out of
concern for the safety of their staff
families with young children have been
able to sleep due to the constant
honking of horns
and this frankly needs to end the last
two years have been incredibly difficult
for every single canadian
the pandemic has impacted the mental
health of canadians in every part of the
country we've missed birthdays holidays
and celebrations with family and with
friends we've had to say goodbye to far
too many loved ones over video calls and
people have felt alone isolated and
scared
we all want this pandemic to be over we
have all made sacrifices and we want to
return to normal as quickly as possible
and we will get there
but the way forward is not by infringing
upon the freedom and rights of your
fellow canadians it's why being getting
vaccinated it's by doing your part to
protect yourself and your community
i want to assure the people of ottawa
that we will continue to support
the city of ottawa and the ottawa police
service in their work as the police of
jurisdiction and i would like to extend
my gratitude as well
to all of the police services that are
assisting in this effort thank you all
very much and i now in late invite to my
colleague minister mendocino
to say a few words
thank you bill uh bonjour monday night
you would like to recognize that i'm
joining you virtually from the
indigenous territories of the algonquin
people
over the past weekend a number of
demonstrations took place across the
country
some were carried out peacefully and in
accordance with the law and this is
thanks to local law enforcement as well
as residents and businesses who showed
patience understanding and respect for
the rule of law during those protests
the people of ottawa however have had to
endure significant disruption to their
daily lives as a result of the ongoing
convoy here
there have been numerous incidents of
intimidation
harassment
violence
and hate
many residents have been effectively
held hostage
in their own city
blockaded by an angry loud
intolerant
and violent crowd
while everyone believes in the right to
free speech
this convoy has crossed the line
of acceptable conduct
towards fellow canadians many many times
now there has been some progress over
the last 12 hours
and there needs to be more progress
and more quickly
i want to commend ottawa police services
for stepping up
enforcement
over 500 tickets laid
charges laid
criminal investigations ongoing
structures are coming down
and this is being safe done safely and
respectfully
in the weeks that follow
we'll need to be really clear
that we can't find ourselves in a
similar situation again
we're also very concerned
about the ongoing situation at the coots
border crossing in alberta
where a group of blockaders continues to
impede access
with important linkages to the united
states
we are grateful to the work of the cbsa
the rcmp
and other officials to ensure that those
lines of supply continue to flow
i want to be clear that there should be
no differences across political parties
in the way that we are dealing with this
moment
it would be a terrible precedent
to say
that if you show up to the nation's
capital
with heavy equipment
and blockade the capital city
that you can force reckless change
in our public policy
it's been surprising that some who say
they believe in law and order
seem not to get this point
for the moment
this is what we can do to support the
ottawa police which is responsible for
applying local laws
since the start the federal government
has been there to support
the s.p.o
throughout the evolution of the
situation the rcmp has approved
requests for additional support
following
a call that i had with mayor watson last
week i was able to confirm that the rcmp
had received and approved an additional
funding request
following another request this weekend
agents have been made available
since saturday the song swanson king's
mom over 275
our cmp agents have been made available
to help
ottawa police and to work under their
command
the rcmp is in talks with ottawa police
and will adapt its support
in accordance with the situation as it
evolves
can help restore the rule of law
i'm discussing with my provincial and
municipal
counterparts and i spoke also with
minister jones
premier kennedy
and
ministers from alberta and the mayor of
ottawa mr watson
the covet 19 pandemic is approaching its
second anniversary in canada
we all want to see a return to normal
life
and a responsible evidence-based easing
of the guidelines and protocols
and i assure you that day is coming soon
canadians have been incredibly united
and have persevered
through it all
the approach our government offered is
about using science and good faith
efforts
to protect ourselves
and one another
because people have chosen this path
thousands of lives have been saved
and we cannot allow an angry crowd to
reverse a course
that continues to save lives
in this last stretch
this should never be a precedent for how
to make policy
in canada
we believe in peace
order
and good government in canada
the stories from communities across the
country
of people sticking together
looking after one another
and giving back
have somehow made this year
a little bit easier
but we can't give up on each other
now more than ever
we need to support one another to work
side by side
regardless of level of government or
party strike to take care of one another
canadians deserve to feel safe in their
communities and no one
is above the law
thank you merci
good afternoon
i want to start off by thanking canadian
truckers
they continue to deliver for canadians
during these challenging times
i continue to meet with truckers and
various representatives and hear their
input
you continue they discontinue
with organizations
community organizations
for organizations i met with truckers in
mississauga and in alberta last monday
representatives of the trucking industry
participated in the supply chain summit
offering important feedback about how to
address real challenges faced by the
industry
this morning i met with the canadian
trucking alliance where we had a
constructive conversation about
addressing the industry's needs and
priorities
they all told me this occupation does
not represent canadian truckers
they also all said that in canada this
is not how we raise concerns and
advocate for policies
these blockades and occupations need to
end
unlawful activities are not the way to
offer meaningful involvement in
government policy development
in addition to engaging the industry
i've also been working with my
provincial counterparts
i've been working with my provincial
counterparts on saturday i met with my
alberta counterpart minister sani where
we exchanged ideas and i offered on
behalf of the federal government our
support
i'm also looking forward to be speak to
be speaking with minister maroony on how
we can work together
the provinces have extensive regulatory
powers over commercial trucking and road
transportation to help end this unlawful
occupation and disruptions of commercial
trucks blockading the streets and
highways
these powers could include for example
quickly enforcing the provisions of the
ontario highway safety to begin
suspending commercial licenses and also
insurance of commercial owners of the
equipment blockading the streets days on
end
in a city or on a highway
it's clear
blockades of streets and bridges is
against the law and should bring serious
consequences for the owners
i would also encourage the province of
ontario to draw on lessons learned from
other provinces on how to use their road
safety authorities to contain unlawful
activities by commercial trucks
we we saw quebec successfully do this
last weekend with the roadside safety
inspections of trucking of trucks
traveling to blockades
i want to assure canadians that we hold
our sacred responsibilities to protect
their health and safety and protect our
economy seriously
we will continue to be guided by the
best advice to manage the pandemic
and as the situation evolved we will
adjust our posture as i am sure
provincial and territorial governments
will
we are all tired of covet 19
but we must remain vigilant and take
advice from our doctors and public
health experts
we must remain vigilant
and now i'd like to pass the mic to my
friend
marco marco
dominic leblanc
thank you very much omar
the ongoing events in ottawa have deeply
shocked canadians
since the beginning of this crisis
our government has been working closely
with our provincial and municipal
partners
in order to determine their needs
and to see how
the federal government can provide
support
i am and will continue to be
along with my cabinet colleagues
in contact with mayors and premiers from
across the country
our government is confident that the
city of ottawa and the province of
ontario
have the tools
and the jurisdiction
to best respond to this crisis
we will continue
to liaise with our provincial and
municipal partners
to put an end to this unacceptable
situation
and as always stand ready as minister
blair said to provide any appropriate
assistance available
hello and thank you for being here
on behalf of residents families workers
businesses and community organizations
of ottawa
ottawa center and the entire national
capital region i say to you
we have had enough this situation must
come to an end our residents workers and
businesses are suffering
our small businesses and community
organizations have shown incredible
resilience throughout this pandemic our
essential services have stood strong
through lockdowns and safety measures
and have helped us keep residents safe
we are here to let you know we stand
with you and we will continue to have
your back
in the past days i have had numerous
conversations with mayor watson i have
also spoken at lengths with city
councillors
representatives of local bias business
and community centers
i have been engaged with concerned
businesses residents and organizations
through countless phone calls
emails and text messages
they have shared first hand with me the
disruptions to their livelihood and
well-being
our residents deserve to feel safe in
their own communities
right now and for the past 10 days
the rights and freedoms of my community
have been restricted and this must come
to an end
i would like to thank my colleagues for
their presence here today
and for their valuable cooperation since
the start of this situation
i would also like to thank my colleagues
in the national capital region who are
at the forefront
of this immense pressure and
difficulties associated with the convoy
government will always support the right
to peaceful protest in canada but we
will also always condemn violence and
threats
and from what we are witnessing on the
ground and hearing from residents this
is the furthest thing from a peaceful
protest we call on the protesters to
stop and respect the communities we
represent
mercies
thank you and i'd like to
give the floor to my colleague from
ottawa
center yes
uh thank you minister good afternoon
no words can accurately describe the
agony of what my community has gone
through
for residents of downtown ottawa this
continues to be a horrific
experience saturn experience
this is a horrible experience
from what my community has seen in the
past 11 days
the protesters actions has not been
peaceful
or lawful
members of my community have been
harassed because of their skin color
yelded for wearing masks
subjected to hurtful and racist symbols
torturous honking
and there are accounts of assaults
parking lots have been used as urinals
fireworks are being hurled down the
streets every night and over the weekend
there was an attempt to light on fire an
apartment building
my heart goes out to the residents of
downtown ottawa who have demonstrated
incredible resiliency
patience and strength
we welcome the enhanced enforcement and
the mayor's decision to declare a state
of emergency
it has to continue until all the
residential streets of downtown ottawa
are free of illegally parked trucks
and restored back to what they were
before so that people can live
peacefully again
this has gone on too long
residents are not unable to sleep
workers and businesses remain once again
severally impacted
this has to stop notre communities
our community deserves to live in peace
i'm glad to see further collaboration
between all levels of government
we must work together to put an end to
this protest and protect
our community thank you maxi
[Music]
thank you we will now move
and alternate between english and french
i'll repeat um so we do have 20 minutes
of questions just a reminder to raise
your hand if you do have a question so i
can uh unmute you on zoom and as usual
we will be altering betw between english
and french questions and uh ministers if
i could ask you since we have limited
time to keep your answers short we'll be
able to have as many uh questions as
possible so on that note i'll start with
the mia rapson from the canadian press
hi yes i'm uh curious if you would be
able to talk about the foreign funding
uh that is alleged to have been behind
much of this the uh impact that that has
on on canada what kind of investigations
can be done and what the laws actually
say or limit about those kinds of of
donations or funding
uh i'm happy to speak to that um
the first thing that i would say is that
obviously to the extent that there may
be any ongoing investigation that is
being carried out by
law enforcement that those
investigations will be
conducted independent of the elected
government
um but i do want to take a moment to
acknowledge the actions that gofundme
has taken
as you will recall
there was
roughly 10 million dollars that was
contributed
to that platform
and as a result of some due diligence
undertaken by gofundme
around the source of those contributions
as well as what they might be used
towards
they suspended the distribution of those
funds
to the convoy on a plain reading of
their statement
there were flags that gave them cause
for concern
i will say that in general terms
we need to be very vigilant
about external forces about foreign
interference uh and that uh that funds
which are being collected are not used
for inappropriate purposes which may
indeed undermine public safety
um at the end of the day uh to the
extent that there is evidence or
information with regards to those
activities
we know and appreciate that they will be
investigated by our independent law
enforcement partners
thank you and i don't know who is best
to answer this question if it's minister
blair or minister mendocino uh there's
been a lot of discussion here today
about that this isn't how canada canada
is a peaceful country um and that the
police have the tools to to manage this
but at least for many people in ottawa
they there are a lot of people calling
this a complete failure of policing even
today as the police chief was talking
about
not allowing any more gas gasoline to
come into the red zone there were
pictures and videos being taken of
people carrying those cans right past
police so can you talk about the
confidence that people should have in
police given what people have witnessed
and if you really do think that the
police have the tools to bring this to
an end
i'm happy to say a few words about that
and then pass on to uh minister blair as
both he and i have extensive experience
uh within the law enforcement context
but
first and foremost
um as i said in my remarks i think there
will be an opportunity for reflection
on on on how
law enforcement has been upheld and
where there have been challenges and i
want to echo the comments that were made
by
everyone on the panel today
of the sympathy that we extend to ottawa
residents who have a right to feel safe
when they leave their homes to move
about their daily lives to be able to
get to work to be able to drop off their
kids to daycare
to essentially be confident that the
rule of law will be upheld
i know that the ottawa police service
has certainly stepped up enforcement
activities and as i mentioned during my
remarks
they should be commended for that and we
will certainly look forward to that
moment where
we will see the conclusion of this
convoy
safely
and responsibly and with the cooperation
of those who have participated
i also want to make the point and it is
important for everyone to appreciate um
that law enforcement does operate
independently of the elected government
we're not a country that believes that
policing should be carried out or be an
extension of the political branch of the
government
there are very good and principal
reasons why the divisions of functions
need to be maintained
separately and clearly within a
democracy
um i'll pass it over to bill blair for
some additional comments
yeah thanks very much marco and you know
as marco has just said it's a very
important principle of our democracy
that that elected officials do not give
direction um with respect to the
investigations or the actions of the
police and and and i know and i spoke
this morning myself to to the minister
responsible for policing in ontario the
solicitor general of ontario um and
she's very mindful of of of her legal
responsibilities to to ensure that the
police have the resources that they need
as we do but but that we are not giving
them direction but i would also point
out um in response to your question
though we have seen a number of um
incidents and evidence of the
effectiveness that law enforcement can
have when they're when they're
adequately resourced that they have the
the tools the authorities and the laws
that they need to effectively manage
this type of the situation we've seen
evidenced in in in toronto and and in
quebec in other jurisdictions across the
country our responsibility here working
working with our provincial and
municipal partners um is to ensure that
the the police of jurisdiction the
ottawa police service has the resources
and the support that they need to to to
do their job and and that's what we are
are committed to doing and at the same
time um you know that i that that should
always be done in a very thoughtful way
so as not to be create a situation where
there would be a perception that that
that
any order of government is giving
direction to the police we're simply
supporting them and doing their job and
make sure that they have the tools and
resources that they need um i'd also
point out by the way that you know i i
will tell you i'm speaking to my
counterpart the minister uh the
solicitor general in ontario they've
been from the very outset of this
ensuring that police services across
ontario the opp have been providing
support and assistance and they'll
continue to do so but we also have
respect for
for the the the authorities and
responsibilities of of the police uh to
to maintain uh peace in their
communities to maintain public order and
to uphold the rule of law
has said sedition in a letter that was
printed in the global mail would you
agree with that epithet for this
protest
i can start with an answer and then
move on to my colleagues including the
minister
i would like to start by
highlighting everyone's
you have to respect the law
you have to respect the rights of
residents of ottawa
leader
there are some leaders of this convoy
that have expressed
[Music]
these statements are not consistent with
canadian
[Music]
[Music]
but in the last few days
there's not a lot of peace in ottawa so
i'd like to give the floor now to
dominic
thank you very much
when we hear things that might indicate
criminal behavior like were expressed by
mr mendicino and mr blair
however the federal government
understands the anger and frustration of
residents
of the ottawa region
my elected colleagues in the region have
expressed it clearly
as they said the federals
the federal government's role is to make
sure that police
authorities who have
the primary and legal responsibility to
settle this issue
and to restore the rule of law in ottawa
have the resources necessary to make the
decisions they need to make and that's
what we will continue to do
your actions are coming a little too
little too late it's the 11th day of
protest
many people have reported crimes that
have been committed
i feel like we
would want to expect a stronger reaction
from the federal government
as i said earlier
i think in the future
in the short-term future
we will have the opportunity to discuss
we will be able to draw lessons learned
from the last week and a half
but right now we need to support the
operations that are underway
we need to support
our police services so that they may act
independently of the federal government
this is one of the foundational
principles of our democracy
there are good reasons
respect police jurisdiction
responsibility
they have the responsibility to
provide operational decisions in the
field
david aiken global news
thank you for taking our questions
minister leblanc some have suggested
that this should be resolved by
negotiations uh with somebody from the
federal side and somebody from the gang
out at the front there what do you think
of that idea
david i'll offer a few comments and my
colleagues may want to pick up as well
we have since the beginning of these
unfortunate events as you said nine ten
days ago been in constant discussions
with municipal and provincial partners
as to what the federal government can
appropriately do
to support the law enforcement
authorities that have the jurisdiction
and the decision-making role
to ensure that public order is kept in
the city of ottawa that's the primary
responsibility for the government of
canada uh
we have certainly taken note uh as my
colleagues have said of the
understandable frustration that
canadians have with the ongoing pandemic
circumstance
our decisions have always been based on
the best advice from doctors from
scientists and what we think is in the
best interest of ensuring the safety and
public health of canadians so those are
the factors that our government
considers when we make decisions
obviously with provincial public health
authorities on the appropriate mix of
measures
so we'll continue to be guided by that
advice but also continue to support
municipal and provincial partners
who have the responsibility in terms of
the circumstances which are so
completely unacceptable unfolding in
ottawa today
but maybe my colleagues want to add
something to that
i'll just say okay minister i think
that's final as somebody wants to say
yes a negotiation is a great idea we've
got a limited amount of time so anybody
want to put their hand up and say
negotiations are a great idea
i'll just move on with my follow-up
sort of cut you off again it's just
we've only got a limited time also
minister leblanc just because you have
the longest personal history with the
prime minister
many say wow the national capital is in
a state of emergency wondering about the
prime minister's comment on the fact
that his national capital is in a state
of emergency a city he lives in
personally has lived here for some time
he's a resident as well as a prime
minister um can you give us an
indication of his involvement in this
this particular predicament um is he
involved in meetings what what and
where's the prime minister
so again the prime minister has been
actively engaged uh every day
uh in briefings uh and in updates from
senior officials in the national
security and intelligence community in
terms of what's happening across the
country in ottawa and across the country
i've had the opportunity to speak and
work with him in meetings right through
this past weekend
and the prime minister has been very
very much involved and continues to be
involved in the operation of the
government of canada and the government
of canada has continued to function as
it must
in a very important public health
context
and we have every reason to think that
that
important work will continue over the
next number of days
uh thank you
before we continue with emily
from the canadian press a little bit
more time for questions until 2 pm so
thank you very much for that thank you
for staying out of berlin
earlier you said that ottawa police
has resources to manage this situation
even though you're giving additional
resources through the rcmp
but for many days the chief of ottawa
police has said that there is no police
solution to this problem
so how do
these two ideas
hold together
[Music]
i would like to mention that the rcmp
added many more resources to support us
ottawa police services
i would like to thank the rcmp
contributions
to keep the communication open between
the ops and the rcmp
we must recognize
that the termination
for once this protest will be over
and conversation
uh
we'll have to start a conversation
it's not acceptable to have
this is a problem for everyone but right
now for our government the priority is
to work together with our partners
we need to work with the provinces and
even the city of
ottawa we have to support the excellent
work of police services
and we have to get to the end of this
convoy and now i'd like to give the
floor to dominic for more
auntie
i completely agree with what my
colleague has just said the main role of
the federal government in such a
situation
is to be there and support municipal and
provincial partners
as my colleagues have explained so
clearly
the interpreter would like to mention
that the sound has cut out
we will resume shortly
mr leblanc your friend has your screen
has frozen
does anyone else want to jump in or do
we move into a follow-up question i will
do my follow-up questions
question mr leblanc was talking about
[Music]
cooperation between municipal and
provincial
levels of government this trilateral
table that was mentioned earlier earlier
what does this change and why do you
announce it today on the 11th day what
will it change
well in the absence of mr leblanc if if
if if i may suggest um what we are doing
is is creating some formal structure
around the important work that has to
take place between all three orders of
government in providing assistance and
support to the city of ottawa and
through our respective police services
to the ottawa police service so that
they can fulfill their responsibilities
it's very clear the legislation in
ontario the police services act in
ontario
creates a responsibility for the police
service and of jurisdiction in this case
the ottawa police service to maintain a
public order and and to provide for law
enforcement and we're we're working
together collaboratively to make sure
that all three orders of government are
there for the city of ottawa and most
importantly for the residents of ottawa
to ensure that their police service has
the resources and the support that they
need to do their job
thank you very much we'll try to
reconnect uh mr leblanc i think he's
here
okay uh we'll go with the next question
uh kevin gallagher ctv news
good afternoon um
can we be specific what type of options
are there for the federal government to
assist
the ottawa police to the city of ottawa
well i think on a practical level kevin
um you've already seen that the rcmp
have stepped up uh by adding 275
mounties who are have been deputized to
enforce um the law locally here in our
communities and again i just want to
commend
them for their exemplary work uh
exemplary work i know that um
the past number of days in ottawa have
been challenging uh for everyone and
especially uh those who live here
um in addition to that there are
funds which the city of ottawa can apply
for within the public safety portfolio
to help offset
some of the additional expenditures and
costs which they have had to incur
as a result of
having to add those resources
the way the law works is that
where the ottawa police service needs
additional capacity and support
they first must turn to
and have turned to
the opp and and that is done in
conjunction with uh my counterpart
minister jones with whom i've had a
number of very constructive
conversations and who uh again to the
credit of the opp uh they too have been
adding resources as that many uh police
services right across the province and
this is another
example of the way in which um we come
together uh in difficult moments um i
think in addition to that you know i
know that uh the mayor in my discussion
with him uh has expressed a real concern
for
those businesses
who have been negatively impacted as a
result of having to remain shut and that
has been caused by the blockades uh the
disruption um the very uh flagrant and
troubling behavior that my colleagues uh
um mp nakvi and minister fortier i think
articulated at the at the beginning of
this press conference
um it is going to be important that
after we bring about the peaceful
resolution of this convoy that we have a
conversation about the ways in which we
can be prepared for such an event um we
need to respect the right to free speech
and assembly that is a an important
element element of our democracy but it
can't come at the expense of public
safety and i think there will be an
important reflection from all of this as
we move forward
i i also would like to add to what
minister medicine has said
is that our officials
uh have been cooperating with provincial
and municipal officials there's a table
where there's ongoing discussions at a
deputy minister's level
for example uh the
ministry of transport has offered ideas
to the ontario ministry of
transportation
where they have powers within
the highway traffic act to enforce
um
violations of that act where
commercial vehicles uh registration can
be suspended or insurance can be
suspended where violators can
be held accountable and
face serious consequences to the
violation of the law
thanks
um for my follow-up i just want to
circle back to
the
foreign interference um what what laws
are there in canada i'm i'm i'm not sure
i'm aware of any like because it doesn't
seem that there's anything that would
prevent a citizen from any country to
donate
to uh you know an online charity
initiative like gofundme that i think is
um actually like registered in
california um
for a charity here like i'm just trying
to understand what
what is the legal process that the
federal government may look at in terms
of what is being called
foreign interference
well first and foremost kevin we have
very strong laws in this country that
are covered extensively in the criminal
code that would legally prohibit anybody
um from contributing to
an effort to undermine public safety or
national security and there are
numerous provisions that that would
apply and so
um if for example that somebody were
contributing with the intent of either
causing public harm or trying to
undermine public safety that would be
something that would be against the law
and there would be appropriate sanctions
for that if proven in the court of law
what you have uh i think in addition to
that is uh an intelligence apparatus
that looks very closely for linkages
between um
the patterns and the sources of those
contributions and what they may be used
for
and if uh some of the sources of those
funds are are beyond our borders then um
you know obviously we would want to be
looking at that very very carefully um
we have a national uh security community
here uh that does exceptional work every
day to be on alert
for any foreign interference that might
undermine our national security
and there are well-established
conventions on how the intelligence side
within the public safety community
shares at the appropriate moment in time
their information their intelligence
with conventional law enforcement so
that where appropriate um
further action may be taken within the
sphere of criminal justice
all of which is to say there are good
strong laws in canada to prevent
foreign interference uh there is a very
robust intelligence community uh to
action uh where appropriate and to flag
to the government where there are
concerns around um threats to national
security and we also have a federal
policing
branch within the rcmp that specializes
in this area and that's why
i'm certainly confident that uh wherever
there's foul play of this sort uh that
we will be in a position to act
appropriately
and
thank you and if i may just add i think
it's also very useful
to keep canadians informed when i think
when they understand the source of some
of this funding it helps them understand
the motivation of this protest who's
actually behind it um and i think it
also reveals um you know
some of you know the the false nature of
the claims being made and and and the
positions being put forward um i think
that that that
casting a light
on on the source of funding that
supports this illegal uh activity taking
place in our in our country um is useful
for all canadians to have a better
understanding of what authorities are
attempting to deal with
announce a trilateral table
what do you tell to ottawa residents
that have been suffering through this
for 11 days do you really think that
this is the solution people are hoping
for
can you
grant more resources to
the police
announced that the emergency measures
act will be invoked do you have any
tangible solutions for these people who
are waiting for
hello answers this is dominic leblanc i
can give you a few comments and maybe
mona or other colleagues can add to it
as minister blair has explained
these measures have been in place since
the start of this crisis
the communication between the three
orders of government
which are the
municipal provincial and federal levels
so we're continuing to collaborate
actively
and we have been doing so since the
start of this event
in addition to that my colleagues have
confirmed that all
requests for support from the province
and the municipality
to the federal government
have been granted
we are always ready
to meet the needs of municipal
authorities who have the legal
responsibility in this circumstance it
is their job to restore order in the
city of ottawa
the federal government has an essential
support role
by providing additional resources to our
partners
but we also want to say like my
colleagues have said
that the time has come for the convoy to
leave they have harassed the residents
of downtown ottawa for
10 days already
the people who want to go to work or
bring their children downtown
can't do so and this must stop the
federal government remains ready to do
what is necessary to support the
authorities who have this responsibility
mona do you want to add something
thank you dominic i think you were very
clear
i would like to add one thing since day
one
in discussion with mayor watson
entrepreneurs workers
we were discussing
how we can support them
since the start of the pandemic our
government has supported businesses and
workers and residents we will continue
to do this we are currently exploring
options
to see
how we can support them
so we will come back with a solution but
know that since the start these
conversations have been happening and
we've been exploring opportunities that
are possible right now
so at this rate mr leblanc do you think
we're still in it for many days or a
week
when will we decide to send in the army
for example to get these protesters out
answer
julian
maybe marco can add to this but the
prime minister was very clear
this is the civilian police's
responsibility
we are here to support
municipal and provincial authorities and
like my colleagues have said it's not up
to politicians to give operational
instructions to police
in taking their responsibilities this is
the role of a responsible government
marco would you like to add something
very quickly i'd like to say that i
agree with you dom
[Music]
the con
[Music]
and we can support law enforcement with
resources
[Music]
we hope that this convoy will leave as
soon as possible
just a reminder to keep your questions
and answers short and will be able to
squeeze in to other people thonda
mccharles toronto star
hi um i wonder if one of you could
react
specifically to the comments by the
texas attorney general this weekend who
said that uh
patriotic texas donors are contributing
to this trucker's convoy and their cause
their worthy cause
and do you consider um that kind of
thing foreign interference
um well i'm happy to take that question
tonda and begin uh by saying um that
it is um
certainly
not the concern
of the texas attorney general
as to how we in canada
go about our daily lives in accordance
with the rule of law
we have rules we have laws um we have
principles we have values
those are all enshrined in the charter
and where those rules are broken um
there is
an appropriate way to address that
through
law enforcement
and what we have been talking about
today
i think is
both
a way of acknowledging the the great
frustration of those who live in ottawa
we've talked about how it's important
that the government can support
police
services who are carrying out their work
independently by giving them
whatever
additional resources that they need
and we've also talked about the need to
be vigilant
about
potential foreign interference
you've seen in the past number of days
that gofundme has taken some
concrete actions to stop the flow of
funds to the leaders who have been
attributed to this convoy and that is as
a result of flags
that have come to their attention
and beyond that um whatever
steps or investigations may be ongoing
and that are being carried out by the
police services
will be done so
in a fashion that is independent from
the elected government
and so
um whatever statements may have been
made
by some foreign official um are neither
here nor there we're canadian we have
our own set of laws and we will follow
them
um
is anyone else commenting on that i'm
not sure but if not i'll go ahead with
my follow-up um
just quickly he's we're all entitled to
an opinion and in my opinion he's wrong
thank you and
look i think
you've left us all here with um you know
your insistence that ottawa has the
ottawa cops have all the tools and
authorities they need but they very
specifically say they don't have the
resources and they don't have the tools
they can't even get rid of in some cases
some of the structures that have been
set up because they have to consult with
ncc or indigenous groups and they they
basically are saying they are their
hands are tied so what i'm hearing from
you guys all say as you know oh that
it's not our jurisdiction in other words
it's not my job and yes there are
clearly jurisdictional lines in normal
times but in a crisis or an emergency
like this how is it that nobody is
seemingly taking the responsibility for
leading the way
well i do think uh tonda as you've heard
explained now very clearly that where
ottawa police service needs additional
capacity that they are being supported
by the opp by other police services and
including the rcmp
and together the the cooperation that is
being seen
among all levels of law enforcement is
resulting in some very concrete and
tangible progress over the last
half day or so and we hope that that
will continue
um we've also talked about the need to
maintain the divisions of function and
for good reason um we don't believe in
uh politicizing law enforcement um there
are some countries that that do things
that way and and and that would not be
appropriate here in canada um i do think
though uh that that there will be an
opportunity in the very near future to
have the kind of conversation that
you're talking about uh to really be
sure that we are capable of responding
to this kind of event event and
preventing it from happening again
what's clear is is that um this kind of
a situation uh is is is not acceptable
uh where you have a blockade where you
have the kind of significant
interruption that we've seen over the
last number of days that has negatively
impacted ottawa residents
and
to work together
across law enforcement across all
governments to come to a better solution
so that it never happens again
in december your government announced
that all employees
in federally regulated workplace would
have to be vaccinated by regulation and
that includes truckers that go from one
provinces to another so i was just
wondering is this still on or given the
circumstances you want to put that on
old
thank you for the question ellen um
we all believe that vaccines are our
best way out of the pandemic
we actually ran a campaign on this just
few months ago and canadians
overwhelmingly voted in support of
parties and elected mps
who
want to help us get out of the pandemic
through by following public health
advice and scientists and doctors
we announced minister
oregon announced last december that we
are now starting the consultation
process
for
examining regulation
to apply uh federally regulated
sectors uh with a vaccine mandate that
work is ongoing so as we've done in the
past we will follow public health advice
we will consult the best best advice
that is before us and this uh and these
discussions are ongoing as we speak
so i gather that you're not backtracking
on this
question
my other question
i remember back in stephen harper's day
liberals were criticizing the
conservative government for preventing
foreign groups in supporting for example
environmentalist groups so if it wasn't
good at the time why is it good now
thank you elaine for the question i
think my colleague mr mendocino has
explained clearly that some laws are in
place in canada
they prevent it in foreign interference
and prevent
inciting events that are illegal and
don't respect current laws in canada
we have intelligence services that are
always at work and trying to identify
security threats to canada
these services are in place to provide
advice to marco mendocino and other law
enforcement
groups
when there is potential foreign
interference
here we're talking about interference
that is inciting
disorderly content
conduct in canada and is funding
entities that are not respecting
canadian law
this is very different
to
compared to
supporting environmentalists work and
then surpri supporting people who are
breaking the law in canada there's a
very important distinction here
there is an obligation to investigate
these matters
this is in the hands of the appropriate
authorities whether it's the canadian
intelligence services or the rcmp but
maybe my colleagues have another thing
to add on this
um well said dominic
well said
marco that's encouraging
we've made a lot of progress
so this is what will bring this press
conference to a close thank you for
being staying a little bit longer
we appreciate it